blizzard casually announced a new
survival game ea is working on three new
star wars titles and more
blizzard has announced that it's working
on a new survival game that's set for pc
and consoles and it's gonna be in a
brand new universe unfortunately that's
about all we know at this point along
with a look at some concept art for the
project a surprise blizzard blog post
reads we are going on a journey to a
whole new universe home to a brand new
survival game for pc and console a place
full of heroes we have yet to meet
stories yet to be told and adventures
yet to be lived a vast realm of
possibility waiting to be explored the
announcement largely serves as a
recruitment ad for the project blizzard
is looking to fill a number of positions
for the game including level designer
lead software engineer senior character
artist and more this new survival game
will be blizzard's first new ips since
overwatch in 2016 and it's been reported
that even some of the most disgruntled
blizzard employees rave about this game
and the team that's working on it the
announcement of the survival game comes
in the wake of microsoft beginning the
process of acquiring activision blizzard
and a 69 billion dollar deal considering
activision blizzard is in the process of
becoming part of microsoft it's unclear
if this new game will come to
playstation or nintendo switch or if it
will be an xbox console exclusive
ea has announced major plans to create
some more star wars games with its
partners and studios developing three
new games in total including a sequel to
jedi fallen order there's also going to
be an fps and a strategy title respawn
is overseeing the development of all
three according to reporter jeff grubb
reespan's new star wars fps is being
made by the same team that developed the
vr game medal of honor above and beyond
however the new game is not a vr title
and is apparently a traditional fps
however ea did not announce any new star
wars battlefront games the series was
headed up by battlefield studio dice
which apparently pitched battlefront 3
but the licensing costs were reportedly
too high all of these titles will be
coming from respawn alongside continued
work on apex legends and another
unannounced new title but it's worth
remembering that ea no longer holds the
exclusive license for star wars games on
console and pc this is why we'll be
seeing a lot more star wars in the not
so distant future ubisoft is developing
its own new open world star wars game
while zynga is making a free to play
shooter called star wars hunters and we
can't forget that the knights of the old
republic remake is also in the works for
ps5 and pc from aspire media jedi fallen
order is a gorgeous game and i still
have friends that hop back into it to
this day are you looking forward to a
sequel let me know why or why not in the
comments
and if you've been keeping up with new
world then a huge patch is coming to
shake up the end game using mutated
expedition orbs which can be crafted or
purchased from faction vendors players
can attempt more challenging versions of
expeditions with different modifiers
each week with extra powerful rewards on
the line players will be scored on their
performance with number of kills wipes
and completion time all factoring into
the equation higher scores means access
to higher difficulties and better
rewards going hand in hand with
expedition mutators is the new umbral
shard upgrade system by gaining umbral
shards from mutated expeditions players
can raise the max gear score of their
equipment up to 6.25 but while in-game
is the focus of the latest new world
update there's plenty of smaller changes
that should go a long way towards
improving the game as well the good news
for players who are still working their
way towards max level the speed at which
players gain levels from levels 25 to 45
is being increased by 20
amazon states that mid game leveling was
taking a bit long and did not match the
pacing of the content fast travel costs
are being dramatically reduced and new
fast travel shrines have also been added
to make traveling to various expeditions
easier owning a home or multiple is
seeing changes as well with the minimum
and maximum tax rates for housing going
down you can find the full patch notes
on gamespot.com
alright there is a ton of star wars
stuff on the way which one are you
looking forward to the most and why let
me know in the comments and as always
leave a like subscribe and tune in
tomorrow for your next gamespot news see
ya
you